safechuck and robson both sued the
jackson estate but their lawsuits were
dismissed because the statute of
limitations
they are now appealing that hbo says
it's airing the documentary to allow
everybody the opportunity to assess the
film and the claims in it for themselves
wesley morris is critic at large for the
new york times he recently wrote
what the times calls one of the paper's
must read articles
headline michael jackson cast a spell
leaving neverland breaks it
wesley morris good morning to you thank
you for joining us hi everybody
so you've heard all the criticism it's
one-sided it's a character association
admitted liars
i want to know your reaction to that and
i'm also curious
your thoughts before you watch the
documentary and your thoughts after
i mean like a lot of people i did not i
mean it's not that i didn't want to see
it but you don't want to have to
deal with what seeing it if the movie
convinces you is going to leave you with
right
and i went in not really
i we we've all lived with what it meant
to have michael jackson be accused of
childhood i've heard these allegations
right yeah i mean he was tried
he was acquitted he settled out of court
um
but this movie is it's convincing and it
is it's
you as an audience member sitting here
watching these two men and their
families talk about
what it meant to have michael jackson in
their lives i mean just setting aside
the child molestation accusations
this is a person who was very much in
the lives of these two people
there is tons of of
evidence that the family has just
mementos
why did you believe them why did i
believe them that's a good question
i think i think some of what makes it
credible is just the degree to which
their similar their stories are similar
and the amount of time
that michael jackson was alone with them
now i know that's going to lead to all
these other questions about
who was responsible or like what role
the parents had
and all of this stuff but that's the way
we treated every other accusation
against michael well you write in the
piece too that one of the most
chilling things for you was the ring
that we just played that he
did that that he knew that michael
jackson knew
this was wrong yeah i mean he said a lot
i mean according to james
and wade james safe chuck and wade
robson michael jackson
seemed to understand the moral the moral
barrier
that sort of made whatever was going on
between
him and james and then him and wade
wrong and
he used the phrase bearing witness
though in your article which i thought
was very interesting
well i mean the movie is i mean the the
film itself is presenting
these stories without a lot of editorial
dissent right this isn't james wait
james and wade sort of saying that
michael jackson did this and you hear
from the family or you hear from lawyers
um this is simply a laying out of a
story
that goes very neatly into the stories
that we've been talking about how do you
see this documentary affecting the other
alleged accusers
who told their stories in the past and
were not believed
of michael jackson yeah um well that's a
great question too
i would love to hear from you know the
arvizos for instance who were part of
that night
were like the objects of that 2003 trial
um where michael jackson was acquitted
mostly be for all kinds of reasons that
trial was a little bit of a fiasco
you remind our viewers about the impact
that michael jackson had
on society and and explain the
difference
that this brings compared to the charges
against bill cosby
and weinstein i mean
it's michael jackson i mean nobody woody
allen
r kelly harvey weinstein
cosby you know bill cosby roman i mean
you know any one of these men matt lauer
nobody has had the sort of cultural
impact that michael jackson has had
michael jackson is responsible for like
i would say 30 percent of the music that
we've gotten since michael jackson
so how do you separate the man who's
accused of these allegations and his
music
what are people who love michael jackson
in the music what are they supposed to
do with this information i mean that's
the question you always ask in these
situations
um what do you do with the work the
person is made
and how do you separate that from the
horrible thing the person has done
i i mean i'm not gonna sidestep that
question i think it's impossible to
answer for one thing in the case of
michael jackson i mean what do you do
you're gonna i'm gonna get on the subway
later there's gonna be somebody playing
guitar
and it's going to be billie jean this
person doesn't know about this
documentary
and doesn't want to know so i i feel
like
that question the real question to ask
is how do we prevent things like this
from happening
again and i think the question the real
question
in the situation in all these situations
whether it's the priesthood
or celebrity is how much power we give
people
and how much faith we put in them and
you know it's fame is a is a disease
celebrity is kind of a religion
and we have to reconcile what we want
our relationship to be with those two
things
and how we want i mean not to be too
much on a tangent here but did you guys
see that kid fluencers
story this weekend that the times ran
it's about
kids who are selling things on instagram
and their parents sort of letting them
do it
this to me seems like a direct
correlation not that
you know anything bad in this way it's
going to happen to these kids but it
seems like michael jackson became famous
at a very early age yeah
well you raise you raise a lot of
questions in this and yeah beautifully
written piece and that's why it's one of
the must read so
thank you for joining us thanks for
having me i'm sorry i was so rambly
not at all it's a complicated subject
you're such a beautiful you're such a
beautiful writer too and this raises so
many questions thank you
thank you thank you